welcome to this video playing seemed
Aaron Cheech Marin let Cheech Marin I
don't think so I'm chili and is not
playing absolutely not playing okay
that's not very exciting I don't know it
is exciting at least a little bit we
have a move okay let's see what is he
coming up with the good ol water Lopez
doing something else adelaide Co Co
variation doing for quick Bishop to d7
okay Bishop g7 yeah was I was recently
oh no he can put it on c3 this assistant
issue I don't know mm-hmm did I capture
too early I don't know I was always I
wanted to check this variation but some
will never found the time it is an
interesting way to play for black it
gets some somewhat more aggressive
positions than many other rural eyes and
it it's less theoretically am demanding
but I'm in the early stages of knowledge
knowledge just may be a far too far too
big word ok is trying to keep this
pinned 95 might be might be on but of
course I have I have active pieces I
wonder ever should actually just take
maybe take it come on trying to play
play it simple night d 5 i also have g5
it looks a bit shaky but ok it wasn't it
wasn't played
my two bishops at least are quite active
maybe I have some threats now with this
unprotected sir bishop on c2 it's trying
to protect it probably with success um
what about 94 or is this I come on let's
act 1 jump to civil ok so night b2 is
ridiculous or not night be to Queen d2
Queen a five and a Z 7s hanging answer
so that's probably probably really
ridiculous um ok I can go to a three but
then you will go to d3 with the bishop
okay maybe just retreat i don't know
those beach one day three squares are
really funky probably not a good idea
from b6 the night at least them again
protects the five okay okay maybe just
screen the Sun getting out of this pin
finally okay what exactly is he doing I
mean there's no made on a seven
half-inch a doubt maybe just wants to
protect this again prepare look you won
something along along these lines okay
night on b6 is not a great piece really
it really isn't I wonder if Queen takes
h3 as possible at some point you know
the bishop won't be seven if some of the
e4 pawn is gone and I mean so sometimes
there are funny tactics it takes pawn
takes would be really nice
okay that didn't happen let's just take
off the whole thing I am and now maybe
just night night away here maybe night
to be fun yeah i can i can go night you
five simply if i want yeah that's that's
a simple solution it's bishop on be one
that's really a bad piece of um the ship
takes now and you can just take what the
bond this this end game is ok for me
it's nothing special nothing great but
it is okay um how do i play probably
activate the bishop by RC 5
really I was thinking that this isn't so
great actually because this is this pawn
can easily become a weakness going to
try to approach it with the king going
over to the six my SG for ideas so after
g4 I need f4 I guess if I mean sorry II
phone I have isolated the point ham so
there are chances to to win it not not
anymore glad that that's not good yeah
that's the way I would for white
unfortunately
not now I have overlooked that move not
good it's really not good I just draw
this game DRA Alfred game drown now that
was this is disappointing really i mean
here i just take some precision to win
the end game which i didn't didn't have
how to do it and I should sure to take
it now we have taken in take it now or
not this move but just a tech the pawn
and and it's gone basically he's too
slow in he's too slow I'm just taking it
next move and he can basically give up
then I was thinking I have all the time
in the world but might have six and G
FOIA and this is already not that clear
and I can actually take you by the way
ah due to the stupid fork trick Oh No ah
it was still great yeah stupid with that
nah i simply i simply couldn't calculate
that I mean not that it is so difficult
but for some reason I didn't see it but
my main problem was that I had
overlooked Bishop H form which of course
makes this thing totally drawn what oh
that was really easy yeah ok let's try
another game thanks for watching